so i don't like the term ceo
um in every other c-level executive
title
their job is in their title
c-f-o-c-m-o-c-o-o
c-t-o like we know exactly what you do
if you don't know how to
work a dvd player we don't make you the
cto if you can't read a balance sheet we
don't make you the cfo
i know that i don't even have to look at
your cv it's in the damn title
what's a ceo what exactly the
responsibility of an executive
officer it's a very ill-defined title
and so we put a lot of people who are
not qualified for that job in that
position
i think we need to change the title to
cvo
chief vision officer someone who's in
charge of setting and ensuring that the
company stays
uh on the path of the vision
somebody has to own the vision and very
often
the co or the cfo which are
head down operator more finite-minded uh
jobs tend to see themselves as in line
for the next
for the big job and it's incorrect it's
not one and two it's one in a
they're complementary skill sets
visionary and operator that have to work
in concert together and so we see a very
very
common mistake um where we
where a visionary founder will promote
their cfo or ceo to take over from them
and we see it all the time um
howard schultz left starbucks put his
ceo on howard starbucks went like this
howard schultz had to come back
mike dell put his co in dell went like
this
uh mike dell had to come back we saw
a mike duke take over walmart
set the company on a horrible path now
doug mcmillan who's more infinite minded
is putting the company back we see this
repeating pattern
and the problem is is because the
relationship
between those complementary skill sets
you know it happened with steve jobs
you take a visionary founder and you say
who should we replace you with
and they say the same thing you have to
put my ceo or my cfo
in my job because i trust them more than
anybody
true i couldn't have done it without
them
true they know more about the workings
of the company than i do
true except it's the wrong skill set
and so what we do is we put operators in
visionary jobs
we put people who've built a skill set
that doesn't mean an operator can't be
more
infinite minded but because we haven't
set up
that they have to completely change the
way they lead
for that what they've been doing for 20
or 30 years they're going to do the
thing that made them successful which is
look down you know a company has a bad
year what does an operator do
cost cut cut costs company is a bad year
what does a visionary do
pivot reinvent and reinvest